we've learned that China's chief
negotiator literally laughed in the face
of Donald Trump in the Oval Office
during recent trade talks that are going
on which of course as I'll show you
momentarily Donald Trump is claiming
we're just so extraordinarily successful
but let me sort of set it up for you and
then we'll get into the new details
Donald Trump campaigned on knowing all
about trade policy and he's going a
fixed trade policy and it's going to be
great for them for the little guy and
for middle America and he's going to end
that trade imbalance with China and
everything's gonna be great and
everybody's just going to be winning big
lis Donald Trump instated some tariffs
it turns out that they actually caused
the opposite rather than reducing the
trade deficit the trade deficit has
increased to record levels Donald Trump
now is claiming on Twitter that maybe
he's not going to need more new tariffs
which were scheduled to be enacted on
March 1st because things are just going
so well in his conversations with China
he tweeted over the weekend quote I am
pleased to report that the US has made
substantial progress in our trade talks
with China on important structural
issues including intellectual property
protection technology transfer
agriculture services currency and method
many other issues as a result of these
very productive talks I will be delaying
the u.s. increase in tariffs now
scheduled for March 1 assuming both
sides make additional progress we will
be planning a summit for President Xi
and myself at Merrill mar-a-lago of
course to conclude an agreement a very
good weekend for the US and China so the
first question is did things actually go
well or is Trump realizing that the
tariffs he's already enacted are
disastrous for the United States and
he's trying to find a way out of
enacting further tariffs the answer to
that question is probably yes but let's
put that issue aside just for a second
and talk about what took place in the
Oval Office it turns out that Trump
exposed in these talks including a
briefly filmed piece of it that he
doesn't understand even the
minor elements of how trade works and
was literally laughed at by a Chinese
negotiator who was in the room in the
Oval Office I'll set the stage for you
either before or after at some point of
the process of these trade discussions
they let cameras into the Oval Office
there's trade officials there
the Chinese vice premier Liu hae is in
there the topic is trade agreements but
Donald Trump gets into this really weird
back-and-forth with Robert light Iser
who's the White House's top negotiator
and they start arguing about mo use and
MOU is a Memorandum of Understanding and
they start arguing over whether an MOU
is a real agreement or merely some kind
of like pre agreement agreement but you
still need the actual agreement later
you'll be able to tell from this video
I'm gonna play for you that Donald Trump
clearly thinks that the MOU is just a
sort of well we'll sort of agree to do
some stuff maybe in principle but Trump
doesn't really believe in MOU is worth
anything the reality is that mo use our
contracts Trump doesn't like the name
more than likely I'm guessing this is
because Donald Trump has had mo use
signed for real-estate deals and he
ended up getting screwed so he thinks
that it's the same thing in politics
that an MoU between two countries isn't
worth anything but it actually it is a
contract so what I'm gonna play for you
here is video of Donald Trump arguing
about this with his own top negotiator
Robert light Iser and Trump in the midst
of arguing with him it's just amazing
he's negotiating with the Chinese
but he's arguing with his own negotiator
over the semantic difference between an
MOU and a deal and an agreement and a
contract you have to sort of listen
carefully but when light Iser explains
to Trump that he's wrong that mo use our
contracts you hear a laugh in the
background and everybody in the room has
said that that was the China Chinese
vice premier Liu Hey
who can't believe what's going on I
think the MOU is going to be very short
term
we expect to go into I don't like mo use
because they don't mean anything to me
that I'll mean anything I think you
thought of just going into a document
I was never never a fan of an MOU refer
to a life interview it's not a therapy
it's an actual contract between the two
parties a Memorandum of Understanding is
a binding agreement between and detail
coverage everything in great detail
it's just call them a memorandum editing
it's a legal term it's a contract
contract last while they last there's no
term they last while they last by the
way I disagree I think that a Memorandum
of Understanding it's not a contract to
the extent that we want so you hear that
laughter in the background which again
was the Chinese Vice Premier who's there
to participate in these negotiations can
you imagine coming to the Oval Office
all the way from China to try to avert
more tariffs which are just mutually
damaging to the US and to China and
Donald Trump is having a semantic
disagreement with his top negotiator in
front of cameras but not one that is
even particularly relevant
he just doesn't agree with the name of
what these agreements are his top
negotiator says this this is not just
like a general term sheet these are
agreements these are contracts these are
binding period and even after this Trump
just continues for another minute
harping on this semantic disagreement
we're doing a Memorandum of
Understanding that will be put into a
final contract I assume but to me the
final contract is really the thing Bob
and I think you mean that too is really
the thing that means something a
Memorandum of Understanding is exactly
that it's a Memorandum of what our
understanding is but to me the contract
is the real question is about so we do a
memorandum of understanding which
frankly you can do or not do I don't
care if you do it or not to me it
doesn't mean very much but if you do a
memorandum how long will it take to put
that into a final binding contract what
trade agreement all right there right no
we'll never use that you're going to
have the state document it's going to be
called it's ready we're never going to
use MOU again are they going to put that
into another again we have two major
hurdles I don't want to put the cart
before it assuming you decide on an
agreement it'll be signed by the two
people it'll be a trainee game of the
things I like that much better I like
that term much with that I don't I
wouldn't go into a member and I would go
right into a trade agreement either
you're gonna make it really good not to
have these other agreements that's a
meaning that would be because they're
not that meaningful in my opinion but
anyway I like that much better this is
this is unbelievable
this is notable for a bunch of different
reasons first of all Trump just doesn't
get it okay
it was explained to him multiple times
in this video that the MOU is a binding
contract and he insists that it's not he
keeps saying either we're gonna do a
deal or we're not I don't care about em
OU's but his chief negotiator you can
see how the propagandizing of all of
this stuff works and how Trump ends up
thinking that he's right and that he's
smarter because Trump is holding up in
an embarrassing way the entire
substantive discussion about what will
the agreement say are we terrifying or
not right those are the relevant
questions Trump is holding up the entire
thing over his understanding of what's
the difference between an MOU and
whatever else
his chief negotiator clearly just to
placate Trump not because Trump's right
because he sees that it's becoming a
huge distraction says hey you know what
we're not going to call it an MOU we're
literally going to have the exact same
document but we're going to change the
title to a trade agreement this doesn't
substantively change anything it merely
placates Trump but then
Trump actually thinks he made a good
point we
knew this was happening behind the
scenes Pat we would learn about how
behind the scenes staffers are endlessly
frustrated with how Trump just doesn't
understand stuff and they have to dumb
things down or appear to acquiesce when
in reality we're talking about semantics
and a 70 something year old man who just
doesn't get it we just saw what normally
happens behind the scenes which is
increasingly frustrated adults in the
room go this guy doesn't get it you want
us to call it an agreement instead of an
MoU they're just crossing out the name
and naming it something else but it's
the exact same thing yeah for us the
veil has been totally lifted the guy
claimed to be a master negotiator we now
know that not to be true he claimed to
be a master when it comes to trade
policy we also know that that's not true
when he doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about there but for his base of
supporters who watch that video and see
that Wow Trump persuaded people in the
room to no longer call that piece and
MOU it's called something else now they
view that as a victory and this is the
type of thing that later Trump will tell
if we didn't have video of this okay
this is one of those things where Trump
will go to a rally and he'll have
written into his speech how he came in
and forced a deal rather than just an
MOU if we didn't have video that
minute-and-a-half
becomes at a rally Trump saying listen
they came in the Chinese came in and my
negotiators came in and if it weren't
for me they would have come out of this
thing with just an MOU and it wouldn't
have gone anywhere but I went in there
and I negotiated because I'm a good
negotiator and I said we're not doing an
MOU were doing an agreement and we're
getting it done and it's going to be
mined by binding and then his Magha
hat-wearing crowd all starts cheering we
now have the video of this and we saw it
was a really dumb semantic disagreement
which led to people who understand stuff
realizing this guy's [ __ ] if he wants
us to change the name of the document
we'll change the name that would be a
minute and a half to two minutes at a
speech of Donald Trump claiming some
kind of big art of the deal negotiation
jury the only other thing I want to say
about this understand now that in the
same way that the adults in the room are
conceding here and saying we'll call it
whatever the hell this guy wants because
we've just got to move on and talk about
the substance this probably leads to a
lot of people acquiescing to trump
stupid demands because he just doesn't
get what is even being discussed and in
order to move things along my guess is
this type of thing where everybody says
oh my god just call it whatever the hell
he wants so we can move on it's probably
happening all the time and in some cases
it's probably more action ibly
significant materially significant than
this particular example this reminds me
this allows me to preview by the way we
are planning an upcoming segment on an
issue in the United States which is an
issue of culture it's an issue of
politics it's an issue of economics and
class and a lot of different things the
growing intellectual divide in the
United States of America this is a real
thing this video is a great opportunity
for me to mention that that's something
that we're working on and we'll have
that coming up for you at some point
very very soon let's take a break make
sure to give us a like on Facebook at
facebook.com slash David Pakman show
plenty more to discuss Donald Trump's
convicted personal attorney Michael
Cohen has been testifying for hours
maybe by the time you watch this maybe
by the time you listen to this it will
be over I have not missed a minute of it
up until I came into the studio to start
working on today's program Michael Cohen
came in armed with documents and
exhibits to support his claims about the
criminality of President Donald Trump
off the top we were told that there
would be a sort of limited scope to
avoid questions related to collusion
with Russia which didn't seem like it
would allow for too much discussion
about that but fortunately because
Michael Cohen included some of those
elements in his opening testimony anyway
there actually have been a fair number
of questions related to Russia it
doesn't look good and we're going to get
to that but if you watched the beginning
of it 15 minutes were devoted solely to
Republican objections that there should
even be testimony Republicans tried to
use procedural rules and technicalities
to prevent the testimony from even
happening I mean desperate to prevent
Michael Cohen from testifying that went
on ten or fifteen minutes before the
event even got going and then Michael
Cohen launched into his opening
statement which was filled absolutely
filled with extraordinary bombshells the
truth of which we'll talk about in a
moment right whether people believe
Michael Cohen is a separate question but
some of what Michael Cohen talked about
in that opening statement includes he
regrets working for Donald Trump and
having done what he did okay I think
anybody would say that in his position
he openly calls Trump a racist a conman
and a cheat and then backs it up and
importantly right off the bat Michael
Cohen confirms that individual number
one in documents related to Cohen's
indictments is indeed Donald Trump he
says that Donald Trump knew Roger stone
was talking to Julian Assange of
WikiLeaks and knew in advance of when
DNC email drops which had been illegally
hacked we're going to be released this
directly contradicts known statements
from multiple people an absolute
bombshell that Donald Trump knew about
this ahead of time this was denied time
and time and time again Michael Cohen
told the story of being in Donald
Trump's office when Roger stone called
on speakerphone and told Trump I just
got off the phone with Julian Assange in
a few days there's going to be this
massive email dump of Hillary Clinton's
emails and Trump responded that it would
be great according to Michael Cohen
which means that indeed Michael Cohen is
testifying that Donald Trump was
involved in the release of the emails
which he made a big deal about during
the campaign as a campaign issue against
Hillary Clinton Michael Cohen talks
about having a check which he brought as
evidence
written by Donald Trump from Trump's
personal account after Trump became
president to reimburse Cohen for the
hush money payments that's a bombshell
Cohen has
multiple copies of these checks cut to
him by Trump while Trump is president to
repay him
for the illegal hush money payments for
which Cohen is going to prison that's a
really important point Cohen is
convicted and is going to prison for the
hush money payments which Donald Trump
paid him back for during the presidency
of Donald Trump Cohen describes talking
to Trump go into the Oval Office and
Trump saying hey those next two payments
are on their way they're being sent in
from new york and it takes a while for
them to work their way through the White
House mail system Cohen presented
financial statements of Donald Trump's
given to banks like Deutsche Bank which
is a bank at the center of this
investigation talks about misuse of
donated funds handwritten notes showing
that Donald Trump arranged and this is
so narcissistic as it is disgusting and
corrupt and a misuse of donated money
Trump arranged for a straw buyer to go
to an auction and buy a portrait of
Trump to go up in one of trumps golf
clubs as we've previously reported which
Donald Trump later reimbursed with
donated funds meant to be charitable
contributions and then Cohen also gets
into what we now know is the truth about
Trump Tower Moscow which is that
negotiations were taking place about
Trump Tower Moscow during the campaign
and what this means is that you
simultaneously had Russia trying to help
Donald Trump defeat Hillary Clinton and
at that same time you had Donald Trump
negotiating to build from Tower Moscow
there were plans a builder had been
lined up there was the idea of giving
Vladimir Putin a 50 million dollar
penthouse as a sort of sweetener to make
the building more appealing to other
oligarchs and Cohen interestingly in the
midst of all this explained how Trump
tells him to lie he says Trump doesn't
show up and say go and lie Trump shows
up and looks at him and says there's no
business in Russia Michael there's no
business in Russia and it's a sort of
wink wink for Michael Cohen to go
out there and to say what Trump knows is
a lie and what Cohen knows is a lie and
what everybody knows is a lie which is
that there actually is business in
Russia this is how a mob boss operates
meanwhile according to Michael Cohen
Trump would ask him regularly how's it
going in Russia how's it going in Russia
because everybody knew that there was
business going on in Russia that's not a
question especially when you ask it six
times that suggests Trump is unconcerned
with what's going on in Russia or the
Trump isn't aware or involved in any of
it racism Cohen says Trump told him
black people would never vote for him
because they were too stupid Cohen says
Trump regularly inflated his assets to
be listed as wealthier on the Forbes
list exactly as we suspect it and might
explain why Trump is desperate for his
tax returns not to become public
Cohen explained that Trump directed him
to threaten lawsuits against Trump
schools if they ever disclosed his
grades or SAT scores because they're
terrible and when it comes to Russia
Cohen says he doesn't have proof but he
has suspicions and he actually tells the
story of a time shortly before the Trump
Tower meeting took place when he was in
Trump's office and in comes Donald Trump
jr. and walks right behind Trump's desk
something that people would rarely do
and leans in close and says quietly but
loud enough for Michael Cohen to hear
that the meeting is all set and Trump
says okay good let me know Michael Cohen
now believes that that was indeed when
Donald Trump was being told that a
meeting with Russian actors meant to
provide dirt on Hillary Clinton had been
arranged had been confirmed and would be
taking place again direct contradiction
of what Donald Trump previously said we
were told by Trump and attorneys and all
sorts of people that hot Trump had no
idea whatsoever about it of course the
more we learn the more we realize that
nothing goes on nothing goes on around
Trump without Donald Trump's specific
involvement and Michael Cohen testified
to that as well today okay
what are going to be the reactions to
this Republicans as I mentioned when in
ready with attack questions and just
trying to attack Michael Cohen's
credibility as someone who can't be
believed Michael Cohen is simply saying
yes I I did lie before and I'm going to
prison for it and I take responsibility
he's there voluntarily it would be
extraordinarily boneheaded I mean Paul
Manafort did it but it would be
extraordinarily boneheaded at this point
to voluntarily put yourself under oath
and tell lies that you know are going to
be scrutinized and could lead to even
more significant jail time prison time
etc so on the one hand playing it
conservatively
if only 5% of what Michael Cohen says
and has said today is true it is a
blockbuster of absolutely historic
proportions that being said I don't
think he's going in there and lying and
again there's not really anything he's
embellishing on you can believe that he
straight-up making everything up whole
cloth right but he's asked questions he
answers them in verifiable ways you can
go and check whether what he says is or
isn't part of the record as he claims it
to be and if we're going to use past
lies as a barometer for determining
whether whether determining whether
someone can be believed in the future
Donald Trump has told according to
different trackers anywhere between
eight and twelve thousand lies as
president of the United States if we
can't believe Michael Cohen ever again
because he said some things that weren't
true to investigators then we can never
believe another word of anything that
Donald Trump says and it's funny I
mentioned that to my audience a lot of
people in my audience already don't
believe anything that Donald Trump says
so the next steps will be testimony will
finish more Democrats and Republicans
will get the opportunity to ask Michael
Cohen questions then we will see the
spin cycle on the news tonight
I may do a YouTube livestream talking
about some of the reaction Democrats
likely will say this points to specific
criminality by Donald Trump that needs
to be further investigated and dug in
to in specific detail new investigations
are necessary we need to call more
witnesses to testify before the House
Oversight Committee Republicans are
going to say we can't believe this guy
this is a bad guy this is a convicted
felon and there's nothing to see here
and ultimately it's going to come down
to Cohen's credibility and what impact
this has on other investigations that
are taking place but to me Michael Cohen
is a guy who at this point has no reason
to lie and has a lot to lose if he's
willing to show up be sworn in and under
oath say things that are demonstrably
untrue and I think we will find out
overtime that today he told the truth
whether consequences will come out of it
whether there will be any willingness by
the Republicans to say you know what
we've got to put party aside and we have
to take this seriously because it is
serious this is the crisis not what's
going on at the us-mexico border then
maybe we will actually see consequences
or the potential of consequences
otherwise I would not be holding my
breath let me know on Twitter what you
make of the testimony whether you think
it will have any actual material impact
on the future of Donald Trump's
presidency I'm skeptical but I'm willing
to have my mind changed on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show
okay massive breaking news regarding not
voter fraud but election fraud right
after the 2018 midterms we started
talking about what's going on in North
Carolina in particular in North
Carolina's ninth district now it's
really important to understand the
difference between voter fraud and
election fraud although really we're
talking about interference with the way
an election should be held but voter
fraud or an election fraud are two
different things in general when we talk
about voter fraud what we mean is
in-person voter fraud voter fraud at the
individual level someone goes to two
different polling places and votes at
both of them that is a form of voter
fraud barely exists extraordinarily rare
someone goes to a polling place knowing
that there
people who have died still on the voter
rolls claims to be those dead people and
votes for them extraordinarily rare
non-citizens going to polling places and
trying to vote exceedingly rare I mean
just it's almost almost non-existent
according to every study that we've seen
what is a problem are different types of
election fraud this includes voter
suppression which includes reducing
voting hours voter intimidation changing
the requirements needed to actually go
and vote requiring IDs which while free
themselves require other documents which
are not free or simple to get voting
machine tampering all sorts of different
ways to do election fraud and what we
had in North Carolina was an absolutely
disgusting example of Republican
election fraud and now a new election
has been ordered the story in North
Carolina's ninth district is of
Republican Mark Harris who narrowly
defeated the Democrat Dan McReady
supposedly by 905 votes
extremely narrow victory but there were
tons of irregularities we found out that
McRae Dallas jr. a known Republican
operative in the area organized a group
of people volunteers paid shills who
knows what whatever they were to go and
collect absentee ballots in person and
we don't know the full scope of what was
done so far but our best assessment is
that they were doing two things number
one the Associates of Dallas would go to
the homes of in particularly known
Democratic areas and claim to be
election workers collecting absentee
ballots if the absentee ballots had
votes for the Democrat they could throw
them out or simply never deliver them so
that they would never be counted
some people gave them ballots which
didn't yet have which were not yet
filled out in those cases they filled
them out for the Republican signed off
as the witnesses themselves and then
the men as fraudulent Republican votes
we also learned that while this was all
being investigated Republicans withheld
damaging information about activities
that they participated in so this was so
bad that a new election was ordered late
last week Republicans are silent and
completely pathetic on this we heard
from the state party chairman Robin
Hayes who issued a statement after this
decision was made saying it was quote a
tremendously difficult situation for all
involved that's one way to call it but a
Republican cheated here what's difficult
is that your guy apparently didn't
really win Donald Trump Trump tweets
about everything Trump claims that voter
fraud is so important that he needed to
concoct this bogus voter election
integrity commission which of course
found no evidence of Hillary Clinton
receiving three to five million illegal
votes in 2016 it was disbanded in shame
having found nothing approximating what
Donald Trump claims exist and Trump has
been completely silent on Twitter about
what's going on in North Carolina in the
Oval Office late last week he was sort
of forced into giving some kind of
answer about it and he said well I
condemn all fraud including North
Carolina
so of course Republicans are silent why
because they try to win with election
fraud while claiming that it's actually
voter fraud that's the problem voter
fraud is not a problem something like 14
convictions for in-person voter fraud
have been uncovered now there's a
counterpoint which is well not everyone
is caught so not everybody gets
convicted even if you accept every
single allegation of voter fraud as
actual fraud you're talking about 0.0002
percent of the votes that are cast
statistically meaningless but we have
Republicans on record saying they can
win with these tactics remember Mike
ters I from Pennsylvania talking about
it he straight up at
mitad voter ID could help Mitt Romney
win we are focused on making sure that
we meet our obligations that we've
talked about for years Pro Second
Amendment the castle doctrine son first
pro-life legislation abortion facility
regulations in 22 years
done voter ID which is going to allow
Governor Romney to win the state of
Pennsylvania done right voter ID they
see it as something that can win them
elections so the questions that now come
up in North Carolina's in ninth district
number one does the Republican Mark
Harris even run in the special election
it's not just a redo of the last
election my understanding is that there
is actually now an actual new election
process and it's possible that Mark
Harris may not even run that's
interesting but more importantly for me
does anybody go to prison here does
anybody go to prison Pat because they
should and if Harris is connected to
this he should go to prison but I think
the most likely scenario is nobody ends
up doing time for really serious
election fraud I totally agree if
there's wrongdoing then people should go
to prison because this is very important
it's the most important thing to our
democratic institution free and fair
elections but hey I am glad that we're
going to have a redo election that
happens very rarely the last time it
happened with the congressional election
was back in the 1970s so I think we can
take that as a win let's go out there
get out the vote and win the seat for
the Democrats yeah this is a really
important thing in general so obviously
in the ninth district in the new
election everybody's got to get out and
vote because imagine if after all this
either mark Harris or another Republican
win again I mean disaster okay that but
we can't allow that to happen
but the message for progressives is if
every progressive votes this stuff what
matters way less because it's too small
a number to really make a difference
unless they become even more blatant so
in this particular case they probably
manipulated more than 905 votes and 900
five votes was the margin of supposed
victory for the Republican okay
they were blatant enough that they got
caught and now we believe we are going
to get a new election great voter
turnout is 40 to 50% in a lot of these
races
if progressives actually turned out in
droves and significantly increased voter
turnout they now need to steal 30% more
50% more twice as many votes in order to
flip the election how are they going to
do that short of actually just changing
numbers in the voting machines in
election machines without creating even
more noticeable activity and a trail of
criminality so yes we need to fix all of
these issues we need to focus on
election fraud and voter suppression
voter fraud is not actually the problem
but we solve 90% of these problems if
every single progressive actually gets
out there and votes and I hope that you
will in 2020 I know I will be voting
starting with a primary at every level
here for for the foreseeable future as I
have been doing for a really long time
make sure to follow the david pakman
show on Instagram where I often do Q&A
sessions with the audience david pakman
show on instagram follow me on instagram
at david pakman as well so I'm going to
start today with the total failure that
was Donald Trump kim jeong-hoon north
korea summit number two and to
understand summit number two you have to
have some sense of the context of summit
number one and as a reminder
historically North Korean leaders have
been very interested in meeting with
American presidents and it's been the
American presidents who have been
uninterested in meeting with North
Korean leaders until and only if they
are willing to agree to some
preconditions because otherwise it would
be seen as a hugely valuable propaganda
accomplishment for the North Korean
leader without any sort of high
likelihood of achieving any change from
the point of view of American presidents
so when Donald Trump before the first
summit with Kim jong-un
bragged that he was able to secure a
meeting with him it exposed that Trump
fundamentally knows nothing about the
history of North Korean relationships
because it's never been a question
whether an American president would be
able to meet with a North Korean leader
the question has been under what
circumstances should a president agree
to such a meeting and of course not
surprisingly after that first summit in
Singapore
Donald Trump came out saying a victory
there's no longer a nuclear threat from
North Korea here's a list of things that
the incredibly funny and smart and and
just great person Kim jong-un has agreed
to do and of course anyone who has been
an observer of the North Korea situation
for any period of time recognized that
it was the exact same vague promises
with no real plan for even observing
whether North Korea sticks to many of
them and as we now know nothing has
happened as a result of that first
summit Trump claimed victory but nothing
has actually changed and in fact we've
been reporting that there has been
continued activity and research and
development of weapon systems in North
Korea that's the set up okay that gets
us to the second summit over the last
couple of days last couple of days
adjusting for a very significant time
zone difference in Vietnam Trump by the
way finally going to Vietnam the bone
spurs notwithstanding he made it to
Vietnam eventually but not until he was
in his 70s and once again no progress
and in fact the negotiations were ended
early and some events were canceled
hilariously the White House schedule
actually planned for what they called a
joint agreement signing ceremony no
agreement to sign so that event
ultimately it was canceled Donald Trump
reported that Kim jong-un was demanding
a total removal of sanctions Trump
saying well I can't actually do that
right now given that you're not doing
anything if Donald Trump is telling the
truth we will listen to how he explained
it and what went down after talks failed
and the entire thing was ended
on North Korea we just left
chairman Kim Wiener really I think a
very productive time we thought and I
thought and secretary Pompeo felt that
it wasn't a good thing to be signing
anything I'm gonna let Mike speak about
it
but we literally just left we spent
pretty much all day with kim jeong-hoon
who is he's quite a guy and quite a
character and I think our relationship
is very strong but at this time we had
some options and at this time we decided
not to do any of the options and we'll
see where that goes but it was it was a
very interesting two days and I think
actually it was a very productive two
days but sometimes you have to walk and
this was just one of those basically
they wanted the sanctions lifted in
their entirety and we couldn't do that
they were willing to denote a large
portion of the areas that we wanted but
we couldn't give up all of the sanctions
for that so we continue to work and
we'll see but we had to walk away from
that particular suggestion we had to
walk away from them okay so Donald Trump
correctly assessing that he can't just
lift all the sanctions a presidential
decision I agree with finally of the
Trump presidency
how funny though calling him quite a guy
and it was productive and the
relationships going great but yet this
is a second summit and literally nothing
has come out of it no progress no deal
and they're still developing missile
sites as of now we're told there's no
plan for a third summit so nothing
substantive other than Trump repeating
that things are going well and he has a
great relationship with Kim jong-un and
he's just an amazing guy now of course
the trumpets have their narrative for
this which is Trump's a tough negotiator
Trump went in there Kim jong-un wanted
something that Trump couldn't give an
end to all sanctions so Trump was the
tough guy and said no and that's a
perfectly fine narrative to try to craft
but it's a win for North Korea to meet
with an American president they've
always wanted to meet with American
president so
going to Vietnam giving Kim jong-un the
photo-op which will be propagandized
within North Korea getting nothing no
progress it's a waste of time
it's a waste of money and it's a waste
of political capital for Donald Trump
and for the United States but the
trumpets don't seem to get it the one
opportunity that is to be taken
advantage of here is the possibility of
pressing Kim jong-un on human rights
issues which Donald Trump obviously
didn't do and why would he Donald Trump
admires the authoritarian dictator types
the White House hilariously unveiling a
commemorative coin for this big event
offering only a thousand of these coins
for $100 each to commemorate this great
day but they may have pulled this I went
on the White House gift shop website
this morning wasn't able to find the
coin may be removed after the entire
thing flopped and the biggest failure if
I'm Trump what I see is the biggest
failure of this summit is not the lack
of an agreement with Kim jong-un it's
that it didn't even work to take
attention away from the Michael Cohen
testimony yesterday Donald Trump met
with Kim jong-un for hours yesterday and
there was almost no coverage in
corporate media other than to mention
that the talks broke down with no
progress all the focus on the Kohen
testimony as it should be Cohen
implicating Donald Trump in multiple
crimes it failed to work even as a
distracting element in the news just a
total and complete failure once again so
Monday night Bernie Sanders did a town
hall event one hour long on CNN a number
of different presidential candidates
have been doing them so far and in
general there's always sort of a
discussion and people end up unhappy
about who gets to ask questions at these
events and at this particular Town Hall
there's more anger than usual because
the assertion is that a lot of the
people who got to ask questions weren't
accurately represented as the political
operatives or lobbyists associated
individuals that they were so I'm going
to lay out the facts here and then we
can kind of think through what the
implications are whether we should be
upset and at
because originally the claim was all of
these secret operatives were planted in
order to make Bernie look bad but it
actually seems to be a little bit more
nuanced than that so we get the Bernie's
Town Hall and I'll go through a few of
these examples and at one point a young
woman gets up to ask a question about
sexual harassment not being taken
seriously by Bernie Sanders during his
2016 campaign and the question was very
scripted which is fine people tend to
plan their questions out ahead of time
and then CNN decides who gets to ask
them but what people are upset about is
that the woman was identified as an
American University student when in fact
although that appears to be true she's
also an intern at a Washington DC
lobbying firm named Cassidy and
associates her name is Dena sob check
out the question check out just a little
bit of Bernie's answer we have a
question from shadi nosov a student at
American University Shaunie's from
Denver as we saw in the 2018 midterms
the Democratic Party has become more
female more racially diverse and younger
in age how can a voter like me feel
confident in your ability to represent
the party especially given that your
response to sexual harassment
allegations during your campaign is that
you were quote a little bit busy running
around the country trying to make the
case to be elected as president well I
think that quote was a little bit out of
context but let me ask you a question I
am enormous ly proud of the fact that we
have the most diverse progressive
freshman class in the history of the
United States Congress and you know what
I did in 2016 and in 2018 I ran all over
this country to try to make that happen
all right so when you talk about the
political revolution you're talking
about two things number one are the
ideas that we are fighting for an
economy that works for all not just the
1% but the second point that I have made
over and over again is we're not going
to be able to implement a progressive
agenda unless millions more people get
involved in the political process yeah
so Bernie answers it perfectly well he
then goes on to say it was very painful
that those allegations were made
okay very quickly people started looking
around and saying okay shoddy an Assad
it says on CNN that she's an American
University student turns out she's a
public policy intern at this lobbyist
Cassady & Associates and people were
able to confirm this by looking at her
LinkedIn Cassady and associates is an
establishment DC lobbying firm it's
connected to Democratic Minority Leader
Harry Reid's former deputy chief of
staff former minority leader who's
currently the CEO they worked for the
Egyptian government to improve Egypt's
image in the US after news of Egyptian
human rights abuses surfaced they were
actually sort of involved in a number of
different political issues and the
argument was this is a plant from an
establishment firm to smear Bernie with
this question but it's not totally clear
that that's when it was the other
argument that has been made is this was
someone who simply teed up for Bernie a
really great opportunity to deal with
the sexual assault sexual harassment
allegations so the question really for
me is are these individuals being
presented in the way that most reflects
their presence at the Town Hall
I'll give you some other examples of
this here's one other one Tara Eversole
okay Tara Eversole was listed as a
former biology professor when she asked
a question if you look at her LinkedIn
profile yes she used to be a biology
professor but right now she's the chair
of the Baltimore County Democratic Party
she's a political operative she's not
just some random former biology
professor now does that tell us whether
her presence is in order to antagonize
Bernie from an establishment point of
view or to help Bernie know it doesn't
it just tells us that the room is filled
with political operatives rather than
just random disinterested voters other
than wanting to figure out who to vote
for another example a woman named Avena
McCallister Avena McCallister presented
as a mother of two and I'm sure she is a
mother of two but according to the
Charles
Democratic Central Committee website she
is a Democratic Committee member she has
a formal position within a local
Democratic Party and I could go on and
on and on there's a whole long list of
these so the question is what does it
matter what does it matter
initially the allegation was CNN
participated in stacking the room with
anti Bernie people to smear him then
people started thinking a little bit
more in a nuanced way about this and
what is the most likely scenario to me
Pat and you tell me if you disagree is
that anytime there's one of these town
halls everybody who has an interest and
that is going to be disproportionately
political groups political operatives
lobbyists etc they try to get their
people in the room obviously they would
try to do that so I think that if
anybody is at fault here it's number one
CNN for maybe not doing enough to get
actual just regular voters in the room
and number two the titles that these
people were assigned I think are
deceptive I totally agree I blame CNN
not getting the right titles or at least
the appropriate titles and I think we
are on edge here and we have the right
to be because Bernie Sanders was screwed
in 2016 not just by the DNC but also by
the establishment media right they
didn't cover his rallies at the
beginning they didn't cover his campaign
meanwhile they were covering Donald
Trump's empty podium and you know had
plenty of interest in Hillary Clinton so
we don't want to see that happen again
in 2020 no and I think a lot of the
discussion about this is wrongly about
debating the merits of a question about
sexual assault because as soon as you
argue that this was a planted shill from
a lobbying group to smear Bernie about
sexual assault
you then have to defend that the sexual
assault questions not valid and while I
agree that sadena Saabs framing was not
a complete framing sexual assaulting
campaigns particularly if you're talking
about women's rights and gender equality
it's a perfectly legitimate question so
for me it's less about pointing to that
question as a smear or a softball I
don't know exactly what that person
lobbying firms interests are in this
election they may well be establishment
and they may be trying to hurt Bernie or
not I just don't know we don't know
exactly what their role is right now
this is sort of breaking news how
candidates deal with sexual assault
matters the question was incorrectly
framed Bernie Sanders answered the
question to the best of his ability
overall what we have to understand is
that this is calculated theater for
television and the sources that have
money are going to disproportionately
have control over the discourse that's
really the message CNN has an interest
in selecting from the questions that are
submitted the ones that they think are
going to be most interesting and
relevant and Cain's a case in point this
question from a lobbyist in turn was
selected to be clipped separately on
CNN's website so CNN has a role to play
lobbying groups and Democratic Party
groups and others know what types of
questions are more likely to be selected
so this is a sort of systemic reality
and focusing on this one question is
relevant but I think it misses the
bigger point there were lots of fluff
softballs during Kamala Harris's Town
Hall many of them were were sort of out
of context or lacking criticism does
that mean that the entire thing was
designed to prop up Kamala Harris maybe
if you believe that the DNC has already
sort of selected her but it could very
much be more a reflection of the
mechanisms that lead to what questions
are written down by people and how CNN
selects them I think what we can all
come away with an agree upon is that a
one-hour town hall which with such
carefully curated questions and no real
opportunity for a back-and-forth doesn't
really give us too much of an
opportunity to learn about the candidate
that's my main complaint